que está impidiendo la llegada de ayuda
a estas zonas de Siria Hola Buenos días
Pues en primer lugar la mayor parte de
la ayuda se está destinando hacia
Turquía que evidentemente es muy
necesario pero no están llegando a
grupos internacionales de rescate como
estamos viendo en Turquía únicamente han
llegado un grupo argelino y un grupo
iraquí para ayudar en las labores de
rescate con lo cual estas labores están
siendo muy lentas y muy precarias porque
no se cuenta en el terreno con ni con
grupos especializados ni con materiales
especializado para poder
sacar a las personas que todavía
continúan debajo de las ruinas con lo
cual la labor está siendo muy muy lenta
mayoritariamente se debe a que en la
zona del norte de Siria hay zonas que
están controladas por el gobierno Pero
hay zonas que están controladas por
otros grupos Rebeldes y grupos armados y
el gobierno sirio no permite que llegue
la ayuda a estas zonas Pero por otro los
organismos los países internacionales de
Estados Unidos la Unión Europea no
quieren destinar ayuda que esté
controlada bajo el gobierno de Siria
sino que quieren destinarlo directamente
a las ongs locales que operan en el
terreno Y esto es lo que el gobierno
sirio está está impidiendo y En qué
situación deja esta situación a las
personas ya anteriormente refugiadas en
esta zona
Pues en principio como digo en que los
rescates estén siendo muy lentos y muy
rudimentarios y en el que haya
muchísimas personas desplazadas en el
que apenas tienen recursos para poder
mantenerse con unas temperaturas muy
bajas durante estos días Tenemos que
tener en cuenta además que en Siria ya
había un brote de cólera los últimos
datos que tenemos son de aproximadamente
86 mil posibles casos de cólera en el
país con lo cual prevemos que esta
situación lo que va a hacer es todavía a
grabar más este brote de cólera no hay
suficientes medicamentos los hospitales
están colapsados no hay tampoco muchos
médicos o enfermeros disponibles Porque
muchos de ellos han huido por la guerra
de Siria y además muchas de las
infraestructuras sanitarias están en
desuso debido a los 12 años de guerra
por otro lado tampoco hay alimentos
ahora mismo para poder abastecer a todas
estas personas desplazadas
por el derrumbe de sus viviendas y por
otro lado también hace falta muchísimo
apoyo psicológico porque en la mayor
parte de las personas están bajo estrés
postraumático
Raquel Martí se habla de 300.000
desplazados internos por el terremoto
entiendo que según lo que me cuentan no
hay un protocolo para la atención de
estas personas y qué es lo que pedirían
ustedes desde su organización
Pues pediríamos que por favor dejaran de
politizar en estos momentos la ayuda
humanitaria que es el pueblo sirio el
que está sufriendo y que se levantara el
embargo en Siria y que se permitiera
entrar a toda la ayuda humanitaria y los
grupos de rescate que hacen falta en
todo el norte del país tanto en las
zonas controladas por el régimen como en
las zonas controladas por otros grupos
armados y que se produjeran las
suficientes donaciones para que los
organismos que estamos en terreno
intentando salvar vidas pues tuvieran
ayuda para poder hacerlo